at nine in the morning it doesn't take
long to get in the expo is fairly empty
at this time of day no long waits to get
into even the most popular pavilions
there are some clusters of high school
students some are German a few of them
were here yesterday already and tell us
what to expect it's the Isle of a bad
morning I've seen a loss but nothing
related to hunger or poverty or anything
like that the theme of this year's Expo
is sustainability and food security the
Brazilian pavilion features a bouncy
landscape made of rope what does this
have to do with nutrition but the
children look happy and the adults don't
seem overly worried we have to take into
account of the expo is just a show and I
think the world has is still a lot to do
to prevent the dream of feeding
everybody in the planet a hundred meters
along we meet someone who takes a
slightly more critical view Mauricio
kazuaki is a scientific advisor to the
expo in charge of the topic of a rice
the expo is meant to present new
research findings about rice cultivation
but most of the pavilions are just
selling souvenirs suspensions is costly
and so they they decided to do a little
market to try to recover money there are
some info panels but Casiraghi is
disappointed with the overall result
most of the people in the world are
basing their diet on rice so it's
something so important and so many
faiths could be saved and done on these
on this topic so i think that is a yeah
we are far from fulfill the slogan of
expo we will win a cluster of rice so
what about food security and
sustainability here there's something
israel's pavilion includes a vertical
rice field with an innovative irrigation
system
and angola is also taking the topic
seriously they're looking at food
storage and preservation apart from that
everything else seems to revolve around
food not feeding the world though but
the expo visitors here in the Russian
pavilion they're dishing up local
specialities hello peasants you what
district representing Russian cuisine
and every two hours there's something to
sample for free good ideas and there are
a few other exhibitors who are taking
the expo slogan seriously here at the
pavilion for development and
humanitarian aid it's a bit out of the
way and not all too many visitors end up
here even though the display area is
empty the organizers are pleased
although we cannot forget that exploits
a business exhibition it's a business
even it managed to bring the topic of
hunger of access to food of
sustainability among the general
public's the expo might not be living up
to its core theme but the students at
least have had a good time